it's a hard life out there for a scout
your position is constantly being
compromised thinks of that oh so
wonderful glare off your scope you're
outgunned whenever enemies close the
distance on you and let's not forget
you're always being hunted by other
Scouts it's not easy being a scout in
battlefield one but here are five tips
to turn your Scout skills into a one-man
death-dealing Menace on the battlefield
one of the most underutilized side
weapons at the Scout carries is his
flare gun
now the basic form of this flare gun
when you use it for the first time is
that it shoots a homing flare that once
on the ground spots all enemies that
step into its range on your mini-map
however once you get the blinding flare
upgrade it turns your flare gun into the
biggest pin the putt that your enemies
have to deal with there are two
functions that this shines in the first
is that it can be used to blind your
enemies both rushing in to disarm an
objective or trying to move in on you to
try to get an easy kill the second it
can be used as an emergency side arm
that can set any foot soldier on fire
causing them to panic everyone right
into your sights tired of giving away
your position when looking for enemies
then you need to grab the binoculars
which you can buy in your equipment menu
these wonder binocs have an excellent
view distance to help you spot
long-range pose for both yourself and
your allies best of all there is no
glare on the lenses so you don't have to
worry about enemy scouts looking to pick
you off
if you really want to do some
hard-hitting damage then you need to
check out the German groover and 95
rifle this rifle doesn't come with a
scope so you don't have to deal with
that cocking animation where that pulls
you out of your line of sights for a
second while you've load up for the next
shot
most importantly this thing packs a
punch and for me personally it is easily
one of most accurate weapons you can get
currently in the beta if you're a master
with iron sights or a first-timer get
used to using this rifle it is best to
try to get used to iron sights because
let's face it maggiore the weapons
you're gonna be using this game don't
have scopes so once you master this gun
you'll be a beast on the battlefield
also don't forget to leave your targets
when using it long range
know what a great combo is to use with
that rifle the incendiary grenade is by
far the grenade of choice when you want
to rack up the kill counter there are
two things you should primary use this
combo for the first is flushing out
camped infantry either above or below
you second it's a great retreat weapon
when say a guy on horseback or an enemy
gets the drop on you and you need to
fall back quick comboing this with your
powerful rifle your enemies will think
twice before engaging you again
locations locations from rooftop windows
to cliffside Heights you should always
be on the move when playing as a scout
what I normally do is that I plant
myself in the location for upwards the
three to four kills then I pack up and
move on any enemy Scout or infantrymen
with half a brain will remember where
you killed them so constantly be on the
move
keeping your enemies guessing as to
where you are so there you have it five
fun Scout tips to give you the upper
hand on the battlefield
always remember to be on the move be an
offensive scout and I'll see you on the
battlefield
provide I don't shoot you in the face
first
you